they ingested some edibles
and it made their prunes taste
incredible
[Laughter]
it's a story of a card playing mama and
brownies made with marijuana yeah they
wanted some sugar and fat and ended up
higher than cat
police in south dakota were called to a
local community center after a group of
senior citizens accidentally ate pot
brownies
and i guarantee that call came from a
landline
according to reports the seniors were
enjoying a game of cards when one woman
shared which he thought were ordinary
homemade brownies prepared by her son
then they really started enjoying that
game of cards
good thing they didn't play strip poker
naked seniors look like they're wearing
corduroy and aegis might say
authorities arrived on the scene to find
everyone under the influence and this
time it wasn't the influence of relief
factor
turns out the brownies weren't the only
thing that got baked that day there was
such an uproar dinner had to be moved
back to 4 30.
police arrested the woman's adult son
who said he had made the brownies the
day before using a half pound of thc
laced butter wow that's more than i used
to lubricate my wetsuit
his 73 year old mom then inadvertently
took them to her card game yeah
inadvertently yeah she gave those
seniors the munchies now she's selling
cottage cheese for eight bucks a bowl
that's what they eat tammy
tammy you're an expert on this aren't
you edibles i i'm i'm not i i did i
tried the marijuana you tried the
marijuana tried the marijuana and it
made me
want to it made me dumb and not thinking
and it made me want to eat twinkies all
day long and that's also not a good look
um but i did date a man when i was in my
late 20s who was known as the chef yeah
in los angeles and he's he did the
edible stuff and he was like he you know
was the beginning he began the entire
craze and he had he had labels of
himself in a chef's hat yeah and for
some i get he was high a lot of the time
i think he didn't realize that when the
police you know they then had a picture
of him yeah they had they had the label
and they knew who the chef was and he
eventually he eventually was arrested uh
but yeah it wasn't it was not my uh my
my deal is he okay now yeah he's an
arsonist i i don't i i have no idea i'm
sure i'm sure he's the head of some
company or
are we just gonna assign them as an
are we just going to aside the fact that
tammy bruce was in season two of narcos
she's gonna roll on as if that didn't
happen how great was this police call
though for the cops
that must have been the funnest call
you've ever been to jimmy they show up
it's like oh it's like it's like the
golden girls meets you know
my cast of hair i don't know hello
officer my grandma's listening to dark
side of the moon
right now
i want to know how they knew they were
stoned when they drove away because like
as a long-time cab driver spent a lot of
time on the road most people that are 80
years old are already doing four miles
an hour with a blinker on the whole time
so how what was the tell you know but i
think that
the ma the kid is not i don't think the
criminal here because the kid made the
brownies the kid didn't bring him in in
some capacity it's the mom right but
what no one's actually talking about is
whether they enjoyed it we didn't hear
hospitalization we didn't hear panic
attack it's your point it's probably the
best game of their life also i i thought
i agreed with you at first okay because
right because the mom stole the brownies
she stole them from the kids she didn't
even ask you know it's like totally your
fault and and you know that this guy
didn't do anything wrong and like who
but then i found out that this guy is a
high school cro choir director oh all of
them oh incarcerated
high school choir director you ever met
a high school choir director that's even
tolerable i hate i hated our high school
choir it was awful of course because he
was a high school choir director you
know i i couldn't stand him so much that
i've googled his name and i still can't
find anything about him and i'm not
going to say his name on the air
father joe
please
[Laughter]
uh
we have to remind ourselves that if you
were 20 in 1964
right now you'd be 77 so it could be
that these people understand pot right
because they were in the 60s and the 70s
right here's i mean here's a totally
different take that we have to consider
here
i was taking the train into the city
today and i was reading this new study
that came out that says that cannabis
compounds actually helps possibly to
prevent covid
so maybe this kid is like a modern-day
robin hood in south dakota and he was
helping these seniors fight covid we
have to consider all of the possible
theories here as well you know possibly
maybe the scientists were a little high
when they were coming out
with this study that they had but if
this is true yeah because there's so
much controversy and friction in this
country as we're we're talking about
mass mandates and vaccine mandates
if you had a universal pot mandate to
cure covet i think that this would bring
everybody together in this country in a
very unifying way with a lot of harmony
i like that solution the one thing i
don't like about is i never understood
pot brownies like do you really need to
save time by combining the drug that
causes munchies with the solution for
munchies well that's what i was just
going to say yeah under this plan we've
gone from 15 days to flatten the curve
to 15 seconds to flatten the bag of
doritos yes it would catch up i actually
think it would work i think i stick with
you on this you're the new fauci
very important topic up next when you're
home alone do you watch stuff your
spouse won't condone